[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de 7,8 le débat nous parlerons
d'économies ce soir à l'occasion des
élections consulaires ce sont les
élections des chambres de commerce et
d'industrie les fameuses cci les
entreprises des yvelines ont jusqu'au 2
novembre pour voter et reconduire la
liste existante ou bien voté pour une
nouvelle équipe alors leur rôle et
parfois méconnus du grand public mais
les chambres de commerce et d'industrie
on détache assez importante celle
d'accompagner les entreprises dans leur
développement elles peuvent également
les orienter sur la formation de leurs
salariés et de façon plus générale les
cci doivent créer du lien entre les
entreprises sur leur territoire et aussi
participer à l'attractivité du
territoire alors les questions que l'on
va se poser ce soir qu'est ce que les
entreprises yvelinoise peuvent
aujourd'hui tirer de cette cci quel est
l'enjeu de cette élection et bien sûr
dans quelle mesure la cci versailles
yvelines peut-elle renforcer la
compétitivité et l'emploi sur le
territoire
avec nous ce soir pour en débattre
les représentants des trois listes
concurrentes
jacques en pinet vous représentez la
liste sortante vous êtes également
président d'une entreprise d'une pme
contrôle 6 qui fabrique des équipements
industriels
monsieur bernard hagège vous êtes vous
représentez la liste ensemble pour les
yvelines et vous êtes vice président de
la cci est également pdg d'at&t mation
si je prononce dirige une pme
spécialisée dans l'informatique
industrielle enfin il veut fouchet vous
êtes tête de liste ump si vous avez
présidé la cci entre 2005 et 2012 je ne
m'abuse et vous êtes également directeur
général d'un cabinet
d'expertise-comptable dbf audit ainsi
bonsoir à vous trois
monsieur jean pinet je me
tourne vers vous vous êtes aux manettes
comment se portent les entreprises des
yvelines aujourd'hui alors écoutez c'est
une excellente question puisque la cia
les produits il y a maintenant trois ans
une analyse de conjoncture des
entreprises illinoise
et cette conjoncture avait l'air de
montrer un prévisionnel pas trop
sympathique puisque nous voyons vous
voyez à l'époque une tendance vers la
baisse des emplois d'une manière
générale or nous avons depuis de
nouveaux éléments le grossiste notamment
je précise ce qu'est le grossiste c'est
à dire le
attendez je retrouve mes notes qui est
en fait un comité d'observation
économique montre en fait une tendance
inverse maintenant depuis peu de temps
avec la création de vingt mille nouveaux
emplois sur les yvelines très bien donc
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important à signaler pour donner je
dirais souffle à nos chefs d'entreprise
nous perd dans une conjoncture qui n'est
pas si facile que ça alors c'est votre
bilan un petit peu
monsieur fouchet vous qui étiez à la
présidence avant ça quel est votre
diagnostic aujourd'hui est ce qu'il ya
des choses que vous regretter de n'avoir
pas mis en place
au niveau de la cci ci haut niveau
l'essentiel là bas j'ai mis beaucoup de
choses en place et d'ailleurs j'ai un
peu l'impression que depuis trois ans et
s'est rien passé de plus j'ai notamment
mis en place la régionalisation qui est
un point majeur
puisque la cci de versailles val d'oise
a fusionné avec la cci de paris est
et aujourd'hui malheureusement
la cci de versailles yvelines
représentée par bernard âgé jacques
empilade d'ailleurs je regrette vivement
que le chef de file de jacques en pinède
n'ai pas pu se déplacer c'est un moment
important
et bien je trouve qu'il s'est pas passé
grand chose et que la visibilité de
notre pauvre chambre n'est plus ce
qu'elle était et est encore moi ce
qu'elles devraient être au niveau
régional alors on va parler de la
réforme juste après je veux laisser la
parole à monsieur hagège de votre côté
qu'est ce qui vous anime pour cette
élection écoutez moi c'est très simple
mon entreprise je les crée voilà 26 ans
avec des collaborateurs j'ai très tôt
sonné à la porte de la chambre de
commerce
elle m'a aidé tout au long je dirais de
ces longues années et je crois que ce
qui m'anime avant tout c'est une volonté
de rendre un petit peu ce qui n'a été
apportée à un moment donné voilà ce qui
me motive pour vous rappeler qu'un et
lit de la chambre de commerce est
d'abord un volontaire c'est d'abord eu
une équipe qui se veut unis pour
travailler ensemble et d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que mathématiquement à
l'issue de ce vote qui a lyon qui est en
cours jusqu'au 2 novembre
l'équipe qui sera constituée
nécessairement sera constitué par des
éléments des candidats issus des trois
listes que vous interrogez ce soir très
bien je vais simplement revenir sur ce
que vous avez émis comme opinion mais se
font chez monsieur en guinée vous qui
représentez la liste sortante qu'est ce
que t'es vous répondre ça ne vous
étonnera pas que je suis en indiquant
que monsieur touchés
c'est embarrassant soir il y avait fait
derrière ceci quand monsieur foucher qui
était président de la chambre des filles
et régionales à l'époque à négocier la
réforme 10 des décès si nous nous sommes
retrouvés dans une situation
complètement pieds et poings liés par
rapport à des décisions régionales donc
nous nous sommes retrouvés dans une
situation alors que nous étions la
deuxième chambre de france entre la cci
du 95 et la cci du 78 parce que nous
étions dans une chambre commune une
version la seconde chambre de france
nous sommes passés maintenant loin
derrière nous sommes devenus cci
départementale 100 rands je dirais
possibilités d'action notamment sur nos
budgets nous nous sommes retrouvés en
plus dans la situation où les dotations
d'état ont été fortement diminué très
fortement diminué pour vous donner un
chiffre la ccir régional est passé
depuis 2013 de 4500 collaborateurs fin
perdu 4500 collaborateurs à
3500 collaborateurs soit moins ville
comme vous avez subi des restrictions de
budget tout ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans oui tout à fait mais dans un
contexte difficile nous avons appris à
faire mieux avant avec beaucoup moins et
aujourd'hui je peux vous faire le
catalogue de tous tu as fait la cci
depuis trois ans sur le rapprochement
des entreprises parce que vous savez
nous ce qui nous apporte c'est pas les
discours
ce ne sont pas les grandes cérémonies
même si en tant qu'élu de la ccit nous
devons bien sûr représenté nos jambes ce
qui nous importe aujourd'hui c'est le
soutien réel concret aux entreprises
dans le quotidien que ce soit le
commerçant que ce soit la pme que ce
soit le grand groupe faire que les
grands groupes puissent trouver chez les
pme de nouveaux fournisseurs localement
et travailler bien sûr en partenariat
avec les
les collectivités territoriales on
reparlera de ce rapprochement que vous
appelez tous de vos voeux bernard hagège
vous voulez ce réagir nécessairement je
voulais compléter un peu ce qui vient
d'être dit à savoir que les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes une étude qui
s'arrête effectivement à 2013 donc ce
n'était pas tout à fait récemment
montrent que ce département a perdu
quelques milliers d'entreprises il n'est
pas le seul d'autres départements
franciliens ont perdu également des
entreprises mais là où c'est beaucoup
plus grave c'est que la contribution au
pibe régional de notre département a
décroché de 18% c'est à dire en gros
nous sommes arrivés aujourd'hui à un
pipe sensiblement égal à celui de
l'essonne alors que nous étions
particulièrement devant ce département
et ma préoccupation est la suivante
c'est comment faire rebondir ce
département alors bien sûr je ne veux
pas dire ici évidemment que la chambre
de commerce y est pour beaucoup c'est
simplement et c'est notre conviction en
tout cas toute l'équipe que je conduis
avec moi c'est notre conviction à savoir
que nous souhaitons redonner un peu de
dynamisme à ce département à savoir
jouer sur ce qu'on appelle
l'attractivité on ne fait pas grand
chose sur l'attractivité on va pas
chercher les entreprises pour leur dire
c'est en yvelines qu'il faut aller on ne
sait pas tout pour empêcher les
entreprises de partir et on fait rien
pour faire en sorte que les entreprises
relocalise chez nous et nous avons un
exemple citer encore où ce matin tout
simplement qu'un fabricant français de
smartphones le seul d'ailleurs à peu
près qui fabrique des smartphones pour
personne on va dire âgées puisque les to
sont plus grandes et caetera et bien a
décidé de relocaliser sa production qui
est aujourd'hui en chine mais il vont à
béziers dans la banlieue de bédié il
aurait pu venir chez nous tout à fait on
en reparlera de cette attractivité il
fauche est un petit mot sur cette
réforme pour terminer sur ce chapitre là
elle s'est passé vous l'avez vous ne
voulez pas du tout pas du tout et ce que
je regrette en revanche c'est
l'incompréhension un peu grave pour un
élu exprimé par par jacques en pin est
d'ailleurs un petit détail vous parlez
de l'équipe sortante l'équipe sortante
elle est là c'est monsieur hagège et
monsieur en pin est en tout cas qui
représentent gerin bacheliers puisque
n'oublions pas quand même que gérard
bacheliers le président et que bernard a
jugé le premier vice président donc non
seulement ils ont échoué mais en plus
ils se sont divisés qu'importe
lalala graveleux grave malentendu ou
incompréhension de jacques en finesse et
que la c6 des yvelines n'est pas devenue
une petite cci départementale nous
faisons partie intégrante de la première
chambre de commerce et d'industrie du
monde grâce à la fusion si les yvelines
n'ont pas été capables ces trois
dernières années de trouver toute
l'expression qu'elle devait avoir au
sein de cet ensemble et régionales je
n'y suis pour rien et je le regrette ils
ont souhaité c'est démocratique prendre
les manettes ils l'ont fait force est de
constater qu'il pleure aujourd'hui une
situation qu'ils ont souhaité donc non
non halal à la fusion et la réforme
était une bonne chose puisque et l'aja
campine a raison de toute façon les
ressources ont beaucoup baissé et comme
les ressources ont beaucoup baissé il
faut travailler sur la mutualisation des
moyens et quelle meilleure façon d
entreprise de savent depuis des lustres
quelle meilleure façon que de fusionner
pour limiter un certain nombre de frais
généraux notamment et là c'est ce que
l'on a fait après que la politique menée
ne soit pas tout à fait la bonne et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je à la
demande d'un certain nombre d'amis je
reviens et c'est parce que à mon avis
est en effet la réforme n'est pas très
très bien mise en place dernier mot
quand même nous avions mis en place
beaucoup de conventions avec les grandes
agglomérations
bien sûr saint quentin en yvelines mais
aussi tout mantois qui est devenue une
communauté urbaine est aussi avec
rambouillet et encore avec les boucles
de seine je ne vois plus revient vivre
de tous à la cci de versailles c'était
la première ses séides en matière de
formation et d'apprentissage je ne vois
pas beaucoup d'élus de cet équipage l'un
s'occupait beaucoup de nos écoles qu'ils
sont brillantissime et qui représentent
le tiers des apprentis consulaires de
l'île de france tout simplement navré un
peu et c'est pour ça que l'équipe la
seule liste d'union patronales
représentant plus d'une douzaine de deux
groupements de deux fédérations
souhaitent redynamiser tout ça alors
redynamiser g vos programmes ici vous
êtes tous d'accord quand même sur les
actions à mettre en place prenons par
exemple ce rapprochement entre les
groupes et les pme vous en avez parlé
jacques en pin est alors bilan de votre
de votre côté oui pour nous le bilan
n'est pas du tout catastrophique comme
le présent qui fauchait vous imaginez
bien et il faut chez ubi simplement de
dire qu' il y avait dans la réforme
territoriale la possibilité que nous
soyons une cci t'es pas une cci
d'essayer à ce moment là et à ce moment
là nous aurions pu pouvoir travailler
nous mêmes sur certains budgets les
réduit les budgets des belges la
jeunesse
j'écoute est sage et c'était bon de la
cci ci or la société qui existe
et qui existent y en a deux qui existent
en région parisienne ont la possibilité
bien sûr de travailler sur leur propre
budget ont leur mot à dire je veux pas
rentrer dans le détail parce que ça me
devront plier bravo sur ce rapprochement
entre l'hier que tu as fait j'y reviens
j'y reviens tout de suite alors ce donc
tout ça pour vous dire que je suis
radical des accords bien évidemment
alors ce que ce que ce rapprochement
justement entre les grands groupes et
les pme qu'avez vous fait pour qu'on
veut c'est un voeu depuis 2013 de notre
président
qui est à nouveau candidat comme vous le
savez et le but c'est en fait de créer
dans des filières donné là notamment
nous quittons le cas puisque je suis en
charge de ce dossier dans la filière
automobile
les yvelines rapprochement entre les
grands groupes industriels
de l'automobile on les connaît il y en a
deux avec l'ensemble du tissu économique
de sous traitants à tous les niveaux on
appelle ça les rend orléans de trois
experts pour concrètement qu'est ce que
vous avez fait aujourd'hui comment vous
les rapprocher alors très concrètement
nous avons reçu la cci a reçu une
commande de la part de la direccte de
travail et donc avec les deux
constructeurs en question et de
travailler sur un certain nombre de
projets que ce soit sur la rh par
exemple les ressources humaines vous
savez par exemple entre les deux
constructeurs
parfois des gens on a besoin un
constructeur a besoin d'un volant de
manoeuvre important parce qu'il est en
train de démarrer une série pendant que
l'autre est en train de terminer sa
série et ce volant de main d'oeuvre
devient dans une dans une des unités de
production d'un des deux groupes
il ya moins de travail pour ce volant de
madame l'idée c'est de mutualiser de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse travailler
sur les ressources humaines de manière à
faire passer les gens d'un site à
l'autre d'assurer ainsi la pérennité de
l'emploi pour les personnes concernées
mais aussi d'avoir des des personnels
qu'ils soient déjà formés aux métiers de
l'automobile et ça c'est fondamental
d'un point de vue de la rentabilité
c'est un exemple il en a beaucoup
d'autres
justement métallisé on en revient à
cette problématique de la compétitivité
bernard hagège kivu à laquelle vous
tenez un petit mot là dessus sur sept
jours et je répondrai à votre question
mais je me dois de réagir un peu ce que
je viens d'entendre de l'un et de
l'autre tout d'abord
dire que il n'ya pas de différence entre
chant territoriale départementale
territoriale
c'est terriblement et rené notre chambre
aujourd'hui
après le traumatisme qu'elle vient de
vivre à savoir plusieurs centaines de
collaborateurs qui ont qui sont partis
ou ont été redistribuées avec tous les
commandants les soucis humain on va dire
que ça représente les traumatismes si je
prends la chambre de l'essonne qui est
une chambre équivalente on prend
économique encore une fois avec une un
type d'entreprises similaires avec la
technologie avec avec du commerce enfin
bref des choses qui ressemblent
il ya 159 collaborateurs si je prends
aujourd'hui la seine et marne et ya 139
collaborateurs avec un pib inférieur à
celui des idées nous avons 58 ou 59
collaborateurs en yvelines nous sommes
très performants tout le monde le sait
les yvelinois sont bien plus performant
que les autres mais malgré tout il
manquera malgré tout quoi comme quoi
qu'on en dise et quel que soit le temps
pour un peu rééquilibré parce qu'il
faudra bien équilibrée un moment donné
il manquera des gens donc des hommes et
des femmes pour aller sur le terrain et
rencontrer les entreprises à leur équipe
à l'horizon mais des équipes en
sollicitant un mac et au menton et en
même temps l'équipe que conduit monsieur
rouge et je pensais pas qu'il y aurait
des attaques directes sur les sur les
têtes de liste mais à ce débat non
l'équipe en l'occurrence qu'il conduit
majoritairement a brillé par son absence
dont nous a semblé il faut être présent
pour faire changer les choses il faut
être présent pour faire bouger les
choses et d'ailleurs je me demande
comment
monsieur foucher ici présents qui
quelqu'un que je connais depuis très
très longtemps et dans l'ain torriente
n'est absolument pas discutable comment
peut-il aujourd'hui briguer un nouveau
mandat de président alors qu'il vient
d'être nommé président du coc des skis
c'est à dire l'entité du développement
économique de saint quentin et fils
alors qu'il brigue la présidence de cci
france il vient d'obtenir d'ailleurs
l'investiture du medef il n'est pas le
seul enfin bref et puis aussi venir
s'occuper et ainsi venir venir s'occuper
non mais c'est pour dire nous n'avons
que 24 heures des uns comme les autres
éléments et je finis avec cela oui
rapidement je file un arrêt cela
l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
demain demain c'est quoi c'est aller
chercher cet argent s'ils sont ces
moyens qui sont aujourd'hui à paris ile
de france et les mettre à la disposition
des yvelinois et pour ça il faut de la
présence il faut du charisme il faut
faire du lobby ce que nous avons
beaucoup moqué de faire c'est vrai ces
dernières années très bien alors nous il
ne nous reste plus que quelques minutes
pour cette mission donc revenons à ma
question sur ce rapprochement entre les
pn les grands groupes est-ce que ça
permet plus de compétitivité pour notre
territoire très rapidement écoutez la
compétitivité du territoire c'est
beaucoup de choses
rapprocher les petits et grands ça me
paraît tout à fait naturel d'ailleurs
c'est une des grandes missions de gens
de commerce parce que pour ceux et
celles qui nous écoutent qui sont pas
forcément des chefs d'entreprise c'est
quoi une chambre de commerce est d'abord
la solidarité entre les grands et les
petits entre les bassins d'emplois qui
vont bien et ceux qui vont moins bien en
ce qu'ils ont ceux qui réussissent et
ceux qui veulent réussir c'est ça une
chambre de commerce après tout nous
l'avons fait pendant des décades entre
le les yvelines le val d'oise on nous a
tellement dit nous étions riches nous
avions beaucoup de moyens on a enrichi
en effet le val d'oise mais de la vierge
notre cette région où en sommes-nous est
faussé
alors j'aimerais quand même qu'on pour
les entrepreneurs qui nous regardent on
revient sur sur celte sur cette question
de comment améliorer la compétitivité de
notre territoire alizés encore une fois
la cci de région est la meilleure chose
qui pouvait arriver
ce que je rappelle quand même bonne fois
pour toutes que c'est la cci de région
qui décide des budgets des départements
y compris pour l'essonne et la seine et
marne et c'est la cci de région qui
tient les contrats de travail de ces
différentes cci donc nous dire qu'on est
des pauvres petits je ne sais quoi c'est
une erreur une erreur de fond une erreur
analyse une erreur grave après les
entreprises et ce territoire des
yvelines auquel je suis très attaché et
dans lequel je travaille et c'est
peut-être pour ça que le président de
saint quentin m'a proposé de présider le
codé ski et je dois bien gérer mes 24
heures puisque jusque là personne ne m'a
demandé de quitter quelques mentions
l'essayant trois mois seront laissés 6
en trois missions une mission de
formation elle est essentielle vous n'en
n'avez pas parlé je le regrette on a de
belles écoles on a trois mille apprentis
on a des grandes écoles comme les hypers
l'école des parfums des écoles à saint
quentin des écoles à rambouillet des
écoles dans la vallée de seine il faut
que nous nous occupions de ces écoles
car ce sont les collaborateurs de demain
et des apprentis qui formeront qui
seront formés dans nos écoles pour nos
entreprises de demain il faut vraiment
que nous travaillons là dessus le
deuxième point c'est la présence
territoriale en relation avec les
collectivités il ya des conventions qui
sont endormis il faut les réveiller car
il ya des projets absolument
considérable je pense à laax scène qui
va de c'est une idée de 2008 2009 mais
elle est très belle qui va de paris
jusque jusqu'au havre on a de bonnes
relations avec les 6 6 2 la vallée de
seine jusqu'au 1 il faut que nous
retravaillons j'entends plus parler de
ce projet qui est gigantesque parce que
derrière ça y'a de l'industrie mais
derrière ça il ya aussi du tourisme et
le troisième donc il faut revitaliser
véritablement toutes ces conventions le
troisième point c'est qu'effectivement
nous également un interlocuteur des
collectivités locales sans vocation
syndicale c'est très important de
rappeler pour faire avancer les grands
projets du territoire et les entreprises
ne se développeront pas s'il n'y a pas
les moyens de transport s'il n'y a pas
les logements pour nos collaborateurs
c'est ça que de vous faire une cci ci ça
que nous avions fait et c'est ça que
nous ambitionnons de fer avec la
douzaine de fédérations qui vous
soutient jacques en pina je vous passe
la parole avant de conclure sur tout à
fait que je vous remercie alors je
voudrais quand même dire une chose et
tout ce qu'on a entendu ce soir c'est
qu'en fait la ccig régional
reconnaît là ses filles des yvelines
comme la cci la plus innovante de toute
la région d'île de france
elle est la première à les considérer
comme la première cci de tous les
départements d'île de france par son
innovation son dynamisme donc ça c'est
quand même à quelque chose qu'il faut
souligner au passage et je n'avais
évidemment pas avec les propos de guy
foucher tout à l'heure sur l'agacement
alors maintenant les partenariats avec
les collectivités territoriales qui est
pour nous extrêmement important je crois
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qui vient
d'y avoir une réforme territoriale que
les territoires ont été fortement
remodelé et que par voie de conséquence
toutes les conventions sont à reprendre
il se trouve que les conventions sont
aujourd'hui en train d'être au moulinet
à la fois du côté des des territoires
mais aussi de la cci c'est pas moins de
300 rendez vous avec les collectivités
territoriales qui se sont déroulées
pendant ces trois ans justement pour
préparer toutes ces nouvelles
conventions et nous y tenons beaucoup
donc la cci a mené un énorme travail
salle et ses onze mille contacts
téléphoniques ses 2100 visite entreprise
c'est 34500 visite d'entreprise à la cci
c'est 3200 porteurs de projets qui ont
été accompagnés c'est 3335 entreprises
participantes à plus de soixante cinq
réunions etc etc etc
aujourd'hui c'est l'ami des catalogues
comment
le terme et je voulais juste se terminer
pour dire pour nous si vous voulez ce
qui est très important ce ne sont pas
les discours car on peut faire d'année
en année des discours ce qui est
important ce sont les actes pour les
commerçants pour les chefs d'entreprise
les pme comme pour les dirigeants des
grands groupes aujourd'hui un tour de
table pour conclure cette émission
bernard hagège vos envies votre ambition
principale pour le territoire pour les
yvelines les entreprises mon ambition
principale
vous l'avez compris c'est pas 35 noeuds
ce n'est pas affaire de programme nous
avons des programmes extrêmement
similaires nous savons très bien ce que
veulent les entreprises et je crois que
nous apportant un certain nombre de
moyens et d'appui mon ambition
principale c'est simplement une équipe
qui est derrière moi qui a la volonté de
travailler ensemble qui est unie sur
laquelle tous les entreprises les hommes
et les femmes pour faire confiance au
quotidien pour la mon ambition c'est de
servir toutes ces entreprises pour les
enjeux de demain c'est-à-dire le
numérique c'est à dire tout ce qui
touche à une chez ces modernes que nous
voulons connectés et d'ailleurs parmi
les premières mesures parmi les
premières mesures je souhaite
véritablement déplacer le siège social
aux bâtiments de verre et d'acier
moderne qui ressemble aux entreprises
qui nous sommes merci berlin avait il
fauche est votre projection pour
l'avenir pour les yvelines elle est
double d'abord 30 secondes redonner à la
cci des yvelines la place qu'elle n'a
plus au sein du conseil régional pour ça
il faut des élus de tempérament qui est
le poids et laurent au niveau du bureau
régional mais ça ça n'intéresse pas les
électeurs pour les électeurs nous
voulons que la cci des yvelines qui
était leader en matière de formation le
soient toujours et le redevienne encore
un peu plus car l'apprentissage est une
voie du succès pour toutes les
entreprises nous voulons dialoguer pas
faire des centaines de débats mais
dialoguer efficacement et avoir des
projets ensemble nous avons une
cinquantaine business des jeux ne
comprend pas pourquoi la cci n'y étaient
pas associées nous voulons aider les
l'école les collectivités à travailler
sur tous les sujets d'infrastructure qui
sont importants pour qu'effectivement
les yvelines redeviennent au niveau 2
consulaires parce que pour le reste ça
va bien et tant mieux ce qu'elle
n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être jacques
en pinaire votre dernier mot oui je
dirai simplement que la formation ne
dépend pas de nous dans le département
mais de la ccr de la région l'ensemble
des écoles sont aujourd'hui gérées au
niveau de la ccr et nos élus régionaux
bien sûr ont déjà géré et continuerons à
gérer je dirais qu'aujourd'hui notre
programme il est pour suivre ce que nous
avons engagées c'est à dire un
rapprochement je répète entre les
entreprises
poursuivre ce travail du hub industriel
de la filière automobile merci ce
rapprochement également entre toutes les
entreprises et les collectivités
territoriales
merci beaucoup à vous trois c'est la fin
de ce 7 8 le débat et on vous rappelle
que le scrutin se déroule jusqu'au 2
novembre
on se retrouve pour une prochaine
émission dans quinze jours merci à vous
[Musique]